hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the crest aggressive did your
dirt server welcome back to dergah
server we're gonna play some Dirk and
we're gonna server and then we're gonna
get you this ladder and we're gonna do
something with it the answer door is
blocked bathroom outside his son isn't
doors blocked but large rocks maybe some
held in here can remove them hmm him how
I don't know I'll see anything else
I built a ladder I thought that was the
only thing that was available to build
hey let me check there was like another
branch off of somewhere that had other
things in it maybe I could go find a
reason to live over there why I doubt
eyes that dramatic but for Simon maybe
someone down this way there's more stuff
don't recall there being anything that I
could attach a ladder to though huh nope
I'm looking up but I'm not seeing
nothing but ow and don't worry guys I
won't let my girl myself get stuck again
I definitely will not let myself get
stuck again aha yeah sorry I was a
little too engrossed in my own
fantasticness I kind of missed that
there might have been monsters but I'm
such a genius don't tell me that was it
oh here we go
stone chipper now I just need a hammer
right huh right right man mark must be
wondering what's going on I mean Simon
took a nap I mean who knows how long he
was out for all right so what do I do
about this who I'm not doing so well so
I got a stone chipper let me just wait
hang on just so I can make sure that I
never have to come back here again I
just absolutely scour this area move
every rock nope nope nope nope okay so
there's no hammer here what was that
hang on there's some there oh there's
more rocks that it is that it there's
more rocks okey-dokey
we will go we will go oh you can see the
brain juices is flowing here
now something collapsed or whatever down
here no not there definitely not there I
don't like walking into blackness so
it's not fun oh oh well maybe I don't
need an actual hammer maybe I just need
one of those those other hammers that I
used God that no sounds need to stop cuz
I keep thinking that looks like a shadow
of uh something
oh man it's freaking me out I mean it's
not as bad as that based god dammit it's
not bad as that basement area but and
it's still not like fun
it's not happy fun times and let me try
this
why is he sound closer and closer I mean
really why he really did sound like he
was standing right behind me that time
and I did not appreciate it darkness
okay then alright to blank if it was
such a strong padlock it wouldn't have
gone so easily all right so I'm guessing
I need some meat why
why
fresh meat this is me don't look too
fresh tell you that I got the chipper
again though dope loop okay
I'm playing around make sure there's
nothing else in here I don't I don't
know why I needed to meet but okay
sounds good was there something down
here that required meat what the hell
when did this happen
oh hi hi um are you gonna bust out that
door okay bye okay thanks bye
what the hell well hi hey buddy can you
um need something to lure out that
monster make my hand
you want some meat glow hi hi hi hi hi
Oh maybe on the table bloop hi hi hi hi
hi come get your meat nice tasty meat
here gonna hide those about any place
you want this meat it's so tender and
juicy oh you want it don't you you want
that me I'll make many didn't chip it I
don't know could you get the juices out
mom oh maybe I need to leave I opted out
at Brewer hey about it not me left okay
all right
I'm gonna let him do his thing go take a
nap again maybe you feeling tired Simon
you're feeling tired or if I can even
get back there's no reason to go back or
maybe about how about that friend of
yours you maybe want to help him get
couldn't build like a bridge for him to
walk across the big hole you spend so
much time building that ladder okay well
so what's the deal here
oh hi yeah you left that's what I
thought
rip please splash bleep dude aah get out
of here it's a scary oh come on
put the meat on the table hi boo you're
scared of me oh there we go
oh oh I tried that I tried to put that
in that and it didn't work I couldn't I
couldn't get it in huh
just messing with me yes games trolling
me this games troll and me no way the
closer want to be or the hammer that I
used over here yep yep
mr lion why don't they just give me a
hammer to put in my inventory why not it
do that that way oh well
shut up I don't like you don't like you
at all
bloop
thunk okay running away now I get the
yes I did
oh yeah I know
finally he shall return I don't know
come on out hey buddy hey buddy hey
buddy what hey hey buddy get back here
buddy
I figured back here don't you be oh yeah
there we go
hi ah why did I need to lure him out I
thought that the meet was probably gonna
be for like busting on the door why did
I need to lure him out hi I'll stare out
at him if it means getting him out of
here get him out here blip blip blip
blip
why what is the deal hi
hey friend oh you gonna you gonna just
stand there be a dick is that what you
gonna do huh Hey ha ha ha well I don't
think that worked um I think that the
designer may have and I may have done a
bug or something I don't know all right
no you stay in there you dick oh yeah I
mean it had some flaws to it I mean I'm
not saying it was terrible in any way it
had like that the dual the dual action
part was very clever and the monster
part was crazy fun I wish I could have
done more with that I hope he does more
in the next ones but either way that was
that was pretty fun I mean the key thing
was kind of bad then the lever thing I
I'll blame myself with a lever thing the
key thing who would ever to think to
look there I mean it's almost impossible
to find took me just random trying to
chuck stuff at a door to get it open
desperation is what made me find it so
anyway so thank you all so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this as much
as I did which is I did enjoy it a lot I
don't get me wrong I mean it has its
flaws but so do ever you so does every
custom story and I'm really I'll be
playing the next part definitely
whenever it comes out which might be a
while because I mean it came out just
recently an amnesia machine for pigs is
right around the corner of next year so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching check out some of the other
custom stories that I've done down below
check out my reaction compilations over
there or over there and check out some
of the other Let's Plays that I've done
thank you again so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye